[Music]
since 2004 world of warcraft has defined
the warcraft name becoming one of the
most famous video games on the planet
it's easy to forget then that this
franchise started as a real-time
strategy game before jumping into the
mmo realm warcraft arclight rumble the
franchise's debut on mobile devices is
blizzard's attempt to bring the warcraft
name back to those strategic routes
here's everything you need to know
we've had access to a preview build of
the game over the last few days and it's
very apparent that arclight rumble
intends to remind us where warcraft
started to resurrect warcraft's past all
while mixing familiar gameplay with
characters and lands built by the mmo's
lore to create an all-new experience
the premise of warcraft arclight rumble
sees coin operated machines appearing in
taverns throughout warcraft's setting of
azeroth where patrons can use miniature
figurines of creatures and heroes to
battle against one another in a
simplified
real-time strategy game players will
collect minis create armies and use them
in both story battles against the ai and
multiplayer matches against other
players it's a similar approach to how
hearthstone uses the tavern as its
setting only exchanging cards for minis
let's be clear about one thing from the
jump while war warcraft arc light rumble
war not bad blizzard follows the
warcraft series familiar real-time
strategy format the depth and complexity
of those older games is not here there's
one resource that needs gathering here
as opposed to three for example and it's
only used for summoning the miniatures
in your army as opposed to units
buildings and more
that said war can serve as a very good
primer for the bygone era of warcraft's
past as the core gameplay feels a lot
like an old school rts the gameplay loop
of war is easy to get a grip on summon
units into one of two lanes and watch as
they slowly progress up to the main
enemy at the top with the overarching
goal of defeating that foe outside of
the occasional arrow appearing on maps
that allows a unit to change lanes as it
passes each unit is fully autonomous
once summoned units can only be summoned
around your base but smaller towers and
summoning stones can be captured on some
maps allowing you to summon a unit
further up on the board once units are
summoned they will travel until they
reach an enemy unit or a boss the enemy
boss at the top of the screen will be
summoning units as well leading to small
skirmishes happening all over the board
as troops happen to meet each other in
their lane as the battle progresses
you'll need to manage your gold
resources efficiently seeing which enemy
units are getting close to your base and
buying units to counter them while at
the same time finding openings in enemy
defenses and exploiting them with strong
units that can make a push to the top of
the board there are some unique
situations to consider during a battle
as well
for example there are two units that can
attack anywhere on the board at any time
chain lightning a spell unit that fires
a quick lightning bolt that will damage
multiple enemies grouped together and
the safe pilot a dwarven pilot that
enters the arena by dive bombing a
designated area
if the boss is low on health either of
these units can end the battle by
themselves as soon as they're summoned
however in the pilot's case if the dive
bomb attack doesn't kill the boss she's
usually toast in one or two attacks
decisions about what units to deploy and
when to roll out your big guns like
these present themselves throughout a
match and making the right call in an
instant is key to victory
missions are carried out on a giant
world map with each section of the map
holding five battles within them winning
all five battles in a region opens the
next region until eventually the entire
map has been defeated each victory also
earns you a skull which acts as a
running tally of how many missions
you've beaten during your playthrough as
the tally rises more ways to play are
unlocked including one-off quests where
you select a unit to power up fight a
battle and if you win the unit gets an
extra boost skulls also unlock pvp
missions where you can battle against
friends and full-on raids where multiple
players can gather together
against the biggest and baddest enemies
in the game all of this can be done
without paying a single cent of real
world money the option to spend money on
new units is available but war doesn't
seem to care if you do or not the army i
was able to amass just through normal
gameplay and in-game currency got me
through the majority of the missions i
played in one try even if some of those
wins were nail biters that weren't
decided until the final seconds while
you can buy units doing so is more for
adding some variety to your army rather
than paying to win units purchased
aren't vastly superior to ones already
in your army or those earned with
in-game currency warcraft arclight
rumble is not the full-on warcraft 3
real-time strategy experience that
old-school feeling however definitely
comes through as you play through each
mission it may not be exactly the same
as the 2001 experience but summoning
units and attacking central points on a
map here in war sometimes feel like
classic warcraft like getting on a brand
new bike as opposed to the one you're
replacing it is also a mobile game which
in itself carries a sort of stigma but i
never felt pressured to spend actual
dollars on this game as i played it
in-game currency came at a steady rate
my units powered up enough that battles
never felt out of reach even if i failed
and nothing was ever locked away behind
a timer as is common with mobile games
it may be hosted on mobile devices but a
lot of what's given the platform a bad
rap has yet to show itself in arclight
rumble it'll take some time to adjust
and some may find themselves going back
to what they're used to but the effort
to bring that classic gameplay back to
the present is evident using the lore of
wow makes a ton of sense too as it lends
a familiarity to the game that those
only accustomed to the mmo can
appreciate it may be a loose fit to some
as war's framing centers around a game
within a game a la hearthstone but the
creatures classes and races of warcraft
both as rts and mmo are here for fans
new and old to appreciate
the press preview build showed off a lot
of the content that will be available in
an upcoming closed beta test which
according to blizzard is coming soon so
it seems pretty close to the full
experience i would like to be able to
play around with units before i purchase
them with real or in-game currency and i
definitely need more exposure to the pvp
and raid content we still don't know how
many players can join a raid at once how
robust the pvp is and so on and i feel
like those will be strong selling points
whether it ultimately will deliver the
best of both worlds remains to be seen
when it launches on ios and android
later this year but as it stands right
now warcraft arclight rumble is off to a
strong start
for more on warcraft art light rumble as
well as the latest on what's happening
with regard to the ongoing legal action
at activision blizzard head over to
gamespot.com
no